can swept through in 2018. wow i did not
know that we call that of course fuel
because we have that also in some of
these areas in california dry dead
vegetation not a lot of rain and it just
fuels that fire when we think wildfire
you automatically go to california and
your schema you're not flying not
necessarily the panhandle no but then
you know they've got to they've got the
everglades there they've got a lot of
spots there they need some of that
florida rain right now yeah they
certainly do you know some of those
storms that come out of nowhere we need
some florida rain here yeah we need
something right here
got a great shot here of the high roller
guys
clear skies tonight wednesday light just
going to be a nice night tonight to go
out and about temperatures will still be
a little chilly in the evening hours
tomorrow we'll warm things up a little
as far as our pollen report goes we told
you the pollen is in the moderate range
but how about air quality right now
everything is good and the reason for
that are the lighter calmer winds we're
seeing outside right now that will
change tomorrow definitely changes on
thursday i would not be surprised if
clark county issues a dust advisory for
thursday specifically 61 degrees our
high for the day today 41 for the low
some of you in the high 30s overnight in
the edges of town 69 is where we should
be so we're still
below average but we'll be near this
tomorrow as our temperatures warm up for
one more day and then come crashing down
the next day 56 right now centennial
hills same for you and summerlin 59 for
the lakes 57 at this hour for downtown
and north las vegas 63 green valley
should say 59 for spring valley as well
54 seven hills
same for you in henderson and same for
southern highlands right now 58 rhodes
ranch spanish trails and mountains edge
outside the valley 57 currently for
prump and 56 in boulder city right now
let's go to the radar network some snow
showers believe or not in the north part
of the state in wells and elko but none
of this is going to reach us we need
some clouds that pass through and still
snow coming down up there in salt lake
city while we remain dry here we're
going to watch that low that's going to
dive down with that trough and as it
does it's going to drag that cold front
through the region this is specifically
going to be on thursday when everything
starts to pop up future cast as far as
showers go don't give us big chances now
this is wednesday thursday in the
morning we could see some isolated
chances around just slight chances and
also in the afternoon too but if we
don't get it it's out of here because by
the time we get to thursday night and
friday we're clearing things up we've
got that limited time window for a
shower chance so we're keeping our
fingers crossed wind forecast does show
those gusts could get up to 40 to 50
between that on thursday this is going
to be the peak wind day breezy winds on
friday after that but the strongest
winds are going to be on thursday 43
overnight chilly and mostly clear skies
70 tomorrow sunny and mild it's going to
feel good tomorrow but then the
temperatures drop like we said by
thursday that's going to be jacket
weather again your 8 day forecast shows
a better weekend with that daylight
saving time temperatures in the 70s and
then 80 next week on tuesday that's your
weather update don't forget to join us
at 11. guys we'll send it back to you
all right ted thanks for that and this
month we celebrate women we want to